نحن في وسط الدار البيضاء اكبري مدن
المغرب كيف وحدت الانجازات التاريخيه
للمنتخب المغربي جماهير الرياضيه التي
كانت منقسمه في كازابلانكا الرجاء والوداد
يتقاسمين احياء وساحات المدينه
واحنا الحين يعني شعب ودادي ورجاوي نقولوا
مجموعين كنا كنا نتسنا وغير نجاح ديال
المغرب يعني وفرحاني بنجاح دياله
احياء واماكن اخرى ضرب السلطان وساحه
الصراخنه العام مو هو نفسه
نشوه التاهل التاريخي من ربع النهائي الى
المربع الذهبي والطموحات
ممكن اقول لهم يزيدك من المستوى اللي
قاعدين فيه وان شاء الله يديه كاس العالم
البهجه والوئام في الدار البيضاء المعروفه
بكونها احدى الواجهات الرئيسيه لسياح
القادمين للمغرب وعاصمتها الاقتصاديه
الثرى في بعض زوارها ومن بينهم هذا السائح
والسعودي
كل كل ما جاءت مباراه
يثبتوها الشعب التواد والتراحم ما بينهم
ولا فرح العارمه
وفي انتظار الاستحقاق القادم يبدو تالق
ممثلين المغرب ملهما بالنسبه لشبان مدينه
هي الاكثر كثافه سكانيه في المملكه خليل
الجنود العربيه الدار البيضاء